I did a casting call for one of the in
minutes videos right and I told people
to send in their demo I remember what
this for yes and so I asked people to
send in their demo reel and most people
send in their demo reel and this and
this guy this [ __ ] doesn't even send
in a demo reel he just sends in a
YouTube video of him doing League of
left leg of legend character precious
why you should also never do that
yourself yeah don't do that we're gonna
someone asked for demos send a demo reel
yeah no I think at the time I didn't
have a character demo chief I still
don't have a character demo reel because
I never needed it okay his things well a
lot of character demos on Twitter you'll
hear them they're really really bad yeah
and the thing is when you're making it
yourself you don't have anyone to say
like hey this kind of sucks so like
every time I've made a professional demo
I've had like a director who's like
hand-chosen every scene and told me what
to do yeah and then it sounds good
because someone who can hear your voice
and be like I'll do this and that but
back then I didn't know that and this is
before I started doing a lot of
professional staff in that yeah it's a
great way to introduce yourself to
someone this is okay this is also
another thing you shouldn't send a demo
to someone if it's garbage cuz you're
gonna like this guy still remembers that
[ __ ] I remember because he was the only
person who didn't send a demo reel or
just sent a YouTube video of him doing
impressions never said like if there is
a like a checklist of things not to say
for a demo do not send character
impressions that's such a big that's
such a big precious good enough I mean
do you remember which characters he did
I think so I think they were like I was
just a bunch of the manly guys from
League of Legends just anyone with a low
voice yeah likes to hide likes no it's
like it's been awesome seeing you how
far you've come from yeah in a character
impression real to you like dude that
was like I thought must have been just
like a year or two after I started as
well and I still like you think that you
figure stuff out after a year but like
you realized when you look back like
Stone you should know share